[Music]
amazon has yet another massive hit on
its hands in the form of reacher the
series has given audiences a towering
new action hero to look up to the first
season of reacher proved an immediate
success for the streaming service
following the former soldier as a
drifter who finds himself embroiled in a
criminal conspiracy in a small georgia
town the show has proven so successful
in fact that it's already been greenlit
for a second season trouble just kind of
seems to find me
the soldier turned detective at the
heart of reacher might look familiar to
fans of the series that's because the
action hero is portrayed by alan richson
an actor with a career full of great
performances in the world of action
comedy with reacher becoming the
monumental hit that it is and with more
action on the way now is the time to
dive in and take a look at some of the
most notable roles and performances that
fans may know alan richton from over the
years one of the first major on-screen
roles that many audience members may
recognize alan richton from is his role
as arthur a.c curry in smallville
introduced to the show during season 5
in 2005 rich then would go on to appear
in the wb superman prequel series four
times until 2010.
you're not going anywhere
the popularity of the aquaman character
on smallville eventually led to a
planned spin-off for the character
however when the aquaman series went to
pilot richson was ultimately recast
despite not playing aquaman in live
action outside of his 10-year old
smallville richson would eventually go
on to reprise his aquaman role and
voiceover for the animated film justice
league the new frontier in 2008. alan
richton has played several athletes over
the course of his career but perhaps his
most well-known athlete performance is
his role as dad castle in the spike tv
comedy series blue mountain state though
initially pitched as a soft antagonist
who bullied and hazed his teammates that
eventually became the co-lead of the
series in the show's second and third
seasons outside of his work in the dc
and reacher universes that castle may
arguably be one of richson's defining
performances as an actor
[Music]
in 2016 richton reprised the role of
thad in earnest for the blue mountain
state spin-off movie blue mountain state
the rise of thadland another high
profile film series where you may have
caught rich sin was the hunger games he
portrayed gloss one of the most gifted
and talented tributes in the games a
career combatant from district 1 who
specialized in throwing knives gloss
battled katniss and the other returning
winners in the hunger games catching
fire alongside his sister cashmere
richton's tenure in the hunger games
franchise was ultimately short-lived if
blue mountain state proved he could
catch a football the hunger game showed
he was just as good at doing it with
arrows but even though gloss went down
richton was going nowhere but up in
hollywood after putting in a few cameos
and popular shows like new girl rich
then landed one of the leads in a very
different type of comic adaptation
teenage mutant ninja turtles although
you couldn't see his face he provided
the voice in motion capture for raphael
actually i'm in charge on this one in
2018 alan richson found himself back in
the dc universe in the role of hank hall
aka hawk and titans a former football
player who eventually became a vigilante
hawk was a brutal fighter who patrolled
the streets in a hawk-themed outfit he
was one half of the hawk and dove crime
fighting duo balancing out the more
nuanced and finesse oriented fighting
style of dove with a brute force
approach as hawk richton would make
several appearances across various dc
properties in addition to his primary
role on titans he also briefly appeared
on supergirl during the crisis on
infinite earth's crossover event
unfortunately for hawke the character
ultimately met his demise during titan
season 3. richson has continued to
appear on titans in sequences following
hank into the afterlife but at this time
the character remains canonically dead
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]